[Applause]
you know it you know it all
right yeah okay okay enough you're
you're eating into my
time it's Friday so you know what that
means let's welcome tonight's guest he's
on Fox and FRS first but in our hearts
he's dead last co-host of fox and FRS
first Todd
pyro as a former Miss Universe judge
she's no stranger to inept hosts host of
The Hoop chat Emily
[Applause]
Austin he gets his fashion advice from
John fedman founder of the lusp
party.com Michael
[Music]
lus and finally he's like a Humvee large
powerful and capable of carrying Arnold
Schwarzenegger New York Times
bestselling author commun former
NW yeah yeah all right all right okay
okay okay before we get to some new
stories let's do
this Greg's
leftovers I don't like my collar but
it's too late to turn
back it makes my head look tiny look at
little Greg's tiny head resting on the
collar looks smug yeah I know I know
it's really funny actually it's
leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading so if they suck
we'll rip off Joe Mackey's nipples and
use them to make pepperoni
pizza according to a new study the cost
of raising a child to age 18 is nearly a
quarter of a million dollars and that's
just to cover the cost of
cocaine by the way Hunter is suing the
IRS for violating his privacy because if
there's one thing we all know about
Hunter Biden there's nothing he values
more than
privacy
this week hundreds of people who
identify as dogs gathered in the center
of Berlin that's Germany they dressed as
a variety of canines including a few
French poodles who immediately rolled
over for the German
Shepherds when the German Shepherd was
asked if he had eight or 10 nipples one
replied
[Laughter]
nine the delivery it delivery Sav yeah
yeah like that's my talent critics of
the Gathering asked what kind of weirdo
becomes an animal that's always sniffing
things president in an unhinged rant
Ukraine transgender spokesperson Sarah
Ashton cerillo said Vlad Putin bathes in
the blood of innocent children and
enjoys it that's nonsense there's only
one person who bathes in children's
blood and she does it on the advice of
her doctor
a new study found that the average
person's home is completely clean less
than 2 weeks a year however this study
may be Irrelevant for people that don't
even own a
[Laughter]
home I like this I like it when we do
that Lauren bobert made news this week
for apparently groping her date during a
theater show hell we should have sent
bobber to look for that missing F35
she's great at finding junk in the
[Laughter]
dark bobert apologized for her behavior
which Dem said was unacceptable it
should only be tolerated in the Oval
Office this week Pope Francis urged
Global action to combat climate change
at the Clinton Global initiative meeting
this from the Vatican who sends black
smoke into the air for weeks to tell us
they haven't picked a pope
yet little religious humor there
apparently very little
the five American hostages who were
released from Iran arrived in our
nation's capital this week once they
arrived and Washington DC all five said
they felt much safer back in
Iran serial sales in the United States
are in sharp decline the situation is so
dire snap crackle and pop were last seen
in the Streets of San
Francisco yeah and no that's not count
chocula on the ground
the Army and Navy are failing to meet
recruiting goals because many potential
recruits are disqualified due to obesity
on the bright side though many go on to
find jobs in
broadcasting a recent oped discussed the
impact on fathers in relation to male to
the male loneliness epidemic but the
article did say that in some cases some
men will be lonely forever oh come
on saw that one coming as always I
embrace loneliness Taylor Swift's
Instagram account has helped register
more than 35,000 new voters it's nice
that she's still on good terms with all
her
[Laughter]
ex-boyfriends this week Joy bear called
presidential candidate VI ramaswami dumb
that's like VI ramaswami calling Joy
bear
[Laughter]
hot it's also the latest evidence that
the only reason to watch the view is to
hear whippy Goldberg
fart and finally Chuck Schumer has
relaxed the Senate dress code so John
fedman can wear whatever he wants it's a
sad day I know I mean even fed's dad
managed to put on a suit
[Applause]
jacket what did Frankenstein do now to
the news Karen can't run faster from the
immigration disaster but if you think
they've secured the Border then you got
a serious mental disorder as tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants pour
into the United States every day the
White House turns a blind eye and in Old
Joe's case two squinty ones and a
drooling lip 10,000 people alone cross
the border on Wednesday it's almost as
if they're being encouraged but Karine
Jean prier could barely keep it together
when asked how Biden will deal with it
so what do you call it here at the White
House when 10,000 people illegally cross
the border in a single day so what do
you call it Peter when GOP puts forth a
a a wait no no no no no no no no you
can't I'm answering okay we're going to
moveing no no no we're moving on you
said stopping the flow at the border no
I tried to answer Peter I tried to
answer the question you stopped me let's
go wow she tried to answer so I guess we
are moving on or so she had hoped okay
we're going to move on no no no no we're
moving on who's talking to Venezuela
about why these people are still coming
who's talking to Panama about the Darian
Gap and who's allowing them to come in
look these diplomatic conversations are
incredibly important the president let's
not forget just last fall brought uh
brought 20 2122 countries together to
talk about what's how migration is
affecting the region this is a president
that has taken historic action on an
issue uh on a system that has been
broken for some time she's stupid
never has someone said less with so many
words you know it's bad when even the
folks from Network news push back CBS
News hasn't shocked us like that since
Charlie Rose let his bathrobe fall open
but good thing Joe put Kamala in charge
of board of security if migrants ask her
for directions they'll end up walking to
Antarctica does Joe care to add
anything no no no look look Jean
Pierre's right The Border's not open and
even if it were uh you'd be fine because
all those people are going to vote for
me I got a lot of credibility with those
people and if you doubt that just ask
any one of them chos on the
Congressional Black Caucus all right
they like me if I could quote Dr Martin
Luther
King the thing on your
finger all
right
you know we're all everybody in America
is upset about this situation it's it's
just beyond belief but Michael it must
really drive you crazy as a homeless
lesbian to see all of our city services
going to migrants while you're out on
the street searching for scraps it's
horrible Greg yes and speaking for the
homeless lesbian
population thanks for having me in here
yes exactly I mean you smell terribly
but but we we were you die out there I
would yes and for just $5 a day
America if you donate let uh this this
is wild to watch the the Karine Jean
Pierre uh Peter Ducey fight it's almost
like uh like watching an old couple an
old married couple fight because you
can't answer a question with a question
you know it's like so so what what does
you call it at the administration what
do you call
it what the what the hell are we doing
here yeah I think uh the GOP should take
the blame for the whole situation and as
part of that uh they should open up
welcome centers at the border where we
take credit for all the giveaways all
the thousands of dollars and encourage
all these new wonderful Americans uh to
vote conservative yeah I think it's a
terrible
idea that border would be shut
tomorrow oh
so president Trump yeah yeah this whole
thing is driven by hatred for Trump it's
like Biden just can't do what Trump did
but to kg kgp or whatever ever her name
is it's like she believes her job is not
to do the job like to OBS youate is that
a word yes okay good but she has a sense
of entitlement Emily that you know
because she's a historic first she
doesn't have to do the job no she does
have a job when she handed in her resume
it was quite clear the only quality
trait they looked for is professional
liar because this woman has never spoken
the truth once out of her mouth I want
to put thank you I want to put a
Pinocchio filter on her nose oh my
goodness and then the truth would be
exposed oh that rhymes I just pulled a
Greg oh there you go wow it's contagious
much like my
infections sorry about that uh Todd I
should have told you first but then you
know we wouldn't have had that wild
weekend it's a hazard of trying to get
on this show
know once a month I do what I have to
do for the infection as
well well it's more like once every six
weeks but who's counting these days Todd
uh doesn't it feel like this whole thing
is intentional because no one's actually
trying to do anything and to your point
Democrats are against what's going on at
the border there are a lot of them but
nevertheless this Administration is
going to do what they are going to do
and I love when kjp does two of the
worst tells in history we have been
clear let me be clear when she say says
we have been clear they have been the
exact opposite and her latest that we
heard In that clip is when she said Joe
Biden has done historic measures his
historically disastrous to our nation
and it's not really a joke because our
nation is in real trouble we do not know
what these individuals are planning to
do in our country there are countless
stories of Chinese military-aged men not
families coming over here looking for a
better life but people seeping across
the border coming into our country and
they have no idea where they are when
they get here our national security is
more and more at risk every day and our
country I talk to an
a Navy SEAL retired Navy SEAL they're
never X special forces guy guy who then
worked for the CIA and he scared the
beesus out of me he said in the next 10
years it's not a Fox News talking point
we will not recognize this country if
this continues and that should frighten
every American Republican Democrat No
Labels regardless I told you not to talk
to other
[Applause]
men I didn't realize that was part of
the monthlong try out to get on this
show I thought it was just the disease
Tyrus it's kind of clear y this is
what's interesting that actually Biden
finally said that he's for this it was
like he' said nothing and now it's like
no we're just going to take him all in
who's running the country that's a
wonderful question I've said it several
times in the show whoever's writing that
notebook that she can't read from is
running the show they have to make the
font bigger because whenever and and
married couple no because that's just
that's not fair to marry couples he
asked a question and whenever a public
official asks answers a question with a
question is this new term that they love
to use forever it's called gaslighting
Remember was everything that was said in
the other Administration is it
gaslighting Trump's gaslighting us well
they're not even they're just lighting
us because we don't have gas because we
shut down the pel yeah so you know
they're solar lighting us but they can't
even tell they it's the progressiv
Democrats Democrats are in a bad
marriage with these progressives and
these Equity highers because let's she's
an equity higher period and she likes to
tell how she's a walking walking history
would like you to walk out and be
history CU you are terrible I don't have
a problem with a different
Administration running their plan but
when their plan is I don't know what do
you do I know you are but what am I
that's that's a problem it's like well
four-year-old talking just admit it
because the Obama Administration didn't
have these problems at the border yeah
Trump's Administration they Titan they
took Obama's stuff took it up in N
letter and we got to the point where we
weren't having these issues just say we
open the gates yeah we open the gates we
don't care and that's it because that's
what they're doing they're just
he's doing historic things one he likes
to say well this the magas did this
magas did this magas mag magas did this
aren't you the same guy who shut down a
whole Pipeline with one swipe of your
pen you couldn't take your pen Mr
President and say finish the wall move
the National Guards over there bring the
military over there you could do it like
that but you can't because you won't
it's true I think it's all uh for a uh a
a solid precise goal to destabilize the
country
that's scary to me that's why my welcome
centers were going to work like
brilliant yes yes hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else